for your pet lover then you know just
how important it is that those animals
are in your life and if you're looking
for love
you want to make sure that that
individual digs your pet
leah isaacson launched the dig app it is
a dating app
for dog lovers across the country until
kobe hit
she then opened it up nationwide to
include more ways for dog lovers to
connect and also to expand their
outreach
with a website called digdates.com
we're doing these yappy hours on dig and
happy hours on tabby
where everyone gets vip access on during
that time so you can talk with everyone
unlimited you can get tips and tricks
from vets and trainers
special deals from different pet
companies
a lot of play on words here the free dig
yappy hour las vegas is happening
tomorrow from four to seven
just log into digdates.com and everyone
gets free messaging during yappy hour
after hearing about the dog lovers app
cat lovers wanted their own so tomorrow
at 4
we'll tell you a little bit more about
that because what's fair is fair